sorry I was talking about Hillary
Clinton and my brain gets scrambled it
excites me so much it's the ideology
that critics say has taken over every
corporation school and college campus in
America and now journalist very ways is
calling for the end of Dei or diversity
equity and inclusion writing quote it
does not believe that America is a good
country at least no better than China or
Iran it calls itself Progressive but it
does not believe in progress it is
explicitly anti-growth it claims to
promote Equity but its answer to the
challenge of teaching math or reading to
disadvantage children is to eliminate
math and reading tests it demonizes hard
work Merit family and the Dignity of the
individual Greg I want to come to you
first about this because I I do think
and Barry Wise has obviously gone
through quite a transformation from her
Uber liberal days um to where she is now
but I do think that this argument that
Society to its detriment has been set up
now as just a battle between the
oppressor and the oppressed is having
more resonance with more people people
especially in light of what's going on
in isra it's a delusion it's a it's a
brainwash and it can be applied anywhere
and basically it argues against any kind
of achievement because you're constantly
blaming anybody who was successful as if
they took it from you Dei pretends to be
an Earnest effort right but it really
was just a corporate play to counter
accusations of greed like for every $25
million bonus the CEO gets he starts
another Equity effort but itend up
hurting the bottom line if you're a
shareholder you can't abide by a company
that puts you know profit draining over
profit making I mean you look at
budlight you look at Disney you look at
Victoria's Secret the consultants and
race Hustlers are the only people that
make money nobody else does you have to
understand that Equity is the opposite
of equality it picks losers and winners
uh independent of skill achievement or
experience it's it's equality from above
which means coercion you have to get
everybody down to do the same so the
standards are lower because individuals
are individuals they're they have
different skills and sets that's why you
have equality of opportunity Equity is
the opposite Dana do you think we will
see a shift back to talking about
equality versus Equity now probably I
mean and when when any anything Barry
Weiss writes I will read I think that
she's an amazing voice of Our Generation
and but I point you to also to I I think
it will matter because some of the stuff
is getting taken to court and they're
winning so in the Wall Street Journal
today I just remember this there was a
editorial about Tennessee's racial
Podi Podiatry Podiatry yeah okay
Podiatry rule so basically it was a
group called Do no harm and they are
dedicated to eliminating racial
discrimination and Healthcare and
there's two boards seats that come up
but they the basically it said only
people that meet the racial mandates can
be doctors on this board which doesn't
make any sense that's no easy
feet so Do no harm is a group that is
helping file these lawsuits to make sure
that actually this kind of thing that is
not right that is not constitutional so
I do think it will change partly because
of all the things that Greg just said
but also because the courts are starting
to get involved and groups like Do no
harm are starting to win these lawsuits
or even before you have to bring a
lawsuit if Do no harm calls you you you
you tend to back off and companies are
eliminating these roles right there was
this huge surge after George Floyd was
murdered in 2020 and that there have
been all these pieces saying that
they're quietly taking down the Dei uh
it's good for shareholders because I was
sucking a lot of cash out of these
companies you can't have perfect
representation you can't have equal
outcomes it's impossible and just
because things are the way they are
Jessica doesn't mean someone's being
discriminated against Thomas Soul writes
this and social justice fallacies sports
and entertainment Jessica over
represented by the Irish blacks and
Southern whites doesn't mean there's
discrimination wine producers and chefs
over represented by the French and the
Italians doesn't mean the English are
being discriminated against whiskey and
beer Industries over represented by the
Scottish and the Germans you don't find
as many successful Jewish people in the
steel or automotive industry but you
find successful Jewish people in ril and
finance how about this one doctors
lawyers from we do it all you do not
steel and automotives from 2010 to 2017
all of the Supreme Court Justices were
either Catholic or Jewish in a country
where it's almost pretty overwhelmingly
Protestant does that mean the
Protestants were being discriminated
against no you look at Silicon Valley
all these people say oh it's
overwhelmingly males well that's because
70% of the computer science phds are
going to men it's just a different pool
of people so everybody's different we
come from different climates geographies
experiences and there's specialization
that takes place over a period of time
and this is what the result is doesn't
make it discriminatory are you saying
women aren't better at that than men are
in the world of Silicon Valley are you
saying as you did yesterday that women
are only better at men at what
what everything that's what I said
yeah taking what Jesse
said it is clear that there are systemic
challenges in society to certain groups
do we risk over correcting and
ignoring those challenges do we risk
overcorrecting yeah we're throwing the
baby out with the bath water okay and
it's real simple this is it is
anti-American it is uh it's gotten to
the point where we're canceling people
out who are good people who are working
hard who are you know involved in truth
hard facts and reality and we're trying
to change the culture to make people
happy who for whatever reason think that
they they don't have the right to do X Y
or Z this is a country where the laws
support you okay and you don't need Dei
to go into every company every Bank
every hospital every school to make sure
that everybody is has the same outcome
CU I don't want somebody flying the
airplane that I'm flying on who's there
because of equity and inclusion and
diversity I want the smartest guy from
the class
guy
Dana coming
up hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else